ravi de vous retrouver vous êtes bien
sur lcp public sénat et c'est l'heure de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour refaire
le tour de l'actu politique et
parlementaire de la semaine avec michael
annett pocatière bonjour à tous bonjour
nickel et on parlera de la loi travaille
encore et toujours à l'ordre du jour
contesté dans la rue discutée à
l'assemblée les députés ont réécrit le
texte totalement modifié par les
sénateurs de longues séances en vue en
attendant de trouver un compromis en cas
d'échec le gouvernement pourrait faire
adopter le texte sans vote par la forte
de l'article 49 3 comme un air de
campagne dont les propositions de
françois hollande
le président de la république pour une
baisse supplémentaire des impôts pour
les plus modestes
dans cet entretien au quotidien les
échos il souhaite aussi d' une réforme
complète des institutions de la vème
république
et puis la question britannique et est
en discussion à l'assemblée et au sénat
débat sans vote mais l'occasion
d'entendre les positions de chacun sur
le choix de 52% des britanniques de
quitter l'union européenne note aussi
ressurgi dans le débat politique
français à la proche de l'élection
présidentielle et pour commenter toute
cette actualité notre invité cette
semaine jean-marie le guen bonjour
bonjour le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement évidemment
on a besoin nous entende et nous
éclairer sur toutes les questions de la
semaine katia où commence évidemment par
lundi lundi ils ont dit oui
55% des électeurs de loire atlantique
ont voté pour le transfert de l'aéroport
de nantes vers notre dame des landes
pour l'exécutif
la messe est presque dite pas pour les
indices qui occupent le site flora
sauvages étaient sur place
c'est le soulagement à
saint-aignan-de-grandlieu une commune
située à côté de nantes est survolée
continuellement par les avions il n'y a
pas que la dame des landes a été fait de
manière anna pacte et aucun moore donc
aucune école direct en loire atlantique
le oui l'a emporté avec 55 % des voix
une victoire pour joël guerriau fervent
partisan du projet il attend maintenant
que le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités rapidement manuel valls
nous a dit dans l'hémicycle très
clairement que si je le oui l'emportait
et bien dès le mois d'octobre
il ferait le nécessaire en particulier
pour que les travaux puissent se
réaliser en évacuant la zone
d'aménagement différé qui est
actuellement occupé que vous savez de
manière totalement illégale
ronan dantec sénateur écologiste fervent
opposant au projet lui assure que cette
consultation ne règle rien avec le break
6 avec la loi les conneries on peut pas
ouvrir un nouveau front
donc moi je suis prêt encore une fois à
m'asseoir autour d'une table avec des
partisans du projet pour trouver des
solutions sur la zad de notre dame des
landes
pas question d'évacuer les lieux les
occupants l'ont promis hier soir rendez
vous a été donné les 9 et 10 juillet
prochains à tous leurs soutiens encore
beaucoup de contestations sur place on
le voit les électeurs se sont prononcés
à l'échelle du département est ce que
pour vous jean marie le guen ce résultat
local a une valeur contraignante
et bien c'est un processus qui a été
souhaité un processus démocratique où
nous avons consulté les personnes
principalement concernés mais au-delà de
ça la quasi-totalité des municipalités
le conseil général le conseil régional
des pays de loire mais aussi le conseil
régional
de bretagne se sont tous prononcés en
faveur de ce projet donc il y à un
moment où il faut respecter la
démocratie à la fois la loi et la
démocratie elle suffrage populaire
moi ce qui me choque dans cette affaire
bon alors on voit bien il ya ce que vous
appelez ce qu'on appelle effectivement
des as 10 parmi eux des gens qui sont de
la zad
il ya des gens voient la zone à défendre
distille oui mais il faut quand même
faire attention nous sommes dans un
monde où il ya beaucoup de tension et
moi je pense que il ya ici et là des
gens qui parlent avec beaucoup de
légèreté d'abord parce qu'on sait les
gens extrêmement violent je fais pas je
dis pas que toutes les personnes
opposées à l'aéroport sont comme cela
mais il ya des gens extrêmement violent
venant de de l'europe entière en quelque
sorte
et puis donc qui ont déjà manifesté un
certain nombre de violences
et puis un processus juridiques et
démocratiques qui reconnaît la nécessité
à la force sur ne parle pas ne partent
pas de même recours à la force possible
recours à la loi la loi est la loi et à
la validation démographie et oui mais
écoutez qu'est ce que c'est qu'un état
qui serait sous la pression assad oncle
gens qui le veulent utiliser la force
pour la réalité elle est là l'état un
train interviendrait où interviendra
avec effectivement une force mais pour
s'opposer à des gens qui s'opposent à la
loi et au vote majoritaire par la force
par la violence qui connaît sarkozy dit
que c'est le résultat de nombreuses
années d'atermoiements démonstration
qu'il n'y a pas d'autorité la tête de
l'état franchement ce projet
effectivement est là depuis longtemps et
notamment pendant les dix ans où il a
été ministre de l'intérieur puis est
donc en charge quelque part du
développement et de l'ordre public et
deuxièmement président de la république
donc il est vraiment la personne la plus
mal placée pour donner des leçons sur ce
sujet alors repasser un autre débat
évidemment qui va vous intéresser c'est
évidemment la loi travail nous sommes
partis
et on commence par la rue 11e journée de
mobilisation des syndicats contre le
projet de loi travail cette fois à de
psychodrame autour du trajet de la
manifestation mais une présence des
forces de l'ordre en nombre un peu plus
de 2500 et pendant ce temps au sénat ils
ont voté le projet de loi largement
modifié corrigé par le sénat à majorité
de droite votent à courte majorité
version qui supprime notamment les 35
heures comme norme est rétabli le
plafonnement des indemnités prud'hommes
du coup le texte est revenu en
discussion à l'assemblée d'abord en
commission puis la semaine prochaine en
séance publique
beaucoup de changements un nouveau texte
mais un compromis est-il encore possible
éléments de réponse avec elsa mon
magasin le bras de fer continue entre
les socialistes mais il devient de plus
en plus feutrée d'un côté le
gouvernement fait des concessions sur la
loi travail myriam el khomri promet de
donner plus de poids aux branches
professionnelles pour encadrer les
accords d'entreprise mais dans ce
nouveau dispositif
la branche ne pourrait pas empêcher des
accords d'entreprise de changer le temps
de travail ou de baisser la rémunération
des heures supplémentaires
le compte n'y est donc toujours pas pour
mettre d'accord tous les socialistes et
le patron des députés ps commence à
avoir du mal à cacher son irritation
nous nous avons fait avec le
gouvernement le chemin que nous devions
faire nous ne sommes pas sur la position
qui était celle du texte qu'il y a
maintenant deux mois il a fortement
évolué je regrette que quelques
syndicats y quelques députés eux
n'évolue jamais la balle est maintenant
dans le camp des frondeurs qui menace
toujours de voter une motion de censure
pour faire barrage à la loi travail pour
éviter une crise certains proposent un
nouveau compromis
ok on maintient la négociation
d'entreprise puisque c'est la
philosophie que le gouvernement veut
introduire dans le droit du travail mais
on met les garde-fous nécessaires et
notamment sur la question des
rémunérations des salariés on ne veut
pas nous que
les entreprises les accords d'entreprise
puisse conduire notamment sur la
question très sensible aujourd'hui pour
nos concitoyens des heures
supplémentaires à des baisses de
rémunération les discussions vont se
poursuivre tout au long du week-end
un vote devrait être organisé dès mardi
au sein du groupe socialiste pour
valider la nouvelle version de la loi
travaille alors pour beaucoup de monde
le compte n'y est pas les députés de la
commission des affaires sociales ont
pourtant travaillé d'arrache-pied pour
essayer de trouver un compromis
ce qui est encore un compromis possible
sur ce texte contesté le compromis il a
eu lieu depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines avec les organisations sociales
et patronales avec les parlementaires il
ya eu plusieurs versions de ce texte on
est loin de la version initiale qui
avait créé c'est vrai une certaine
émotion il faut pas le pas le cacher
même si à mon avis elle avait été
victime de deux polémiques plus que de
vérité mais ces compromis ils ont eu
lieu donc je voudrais pardon il aura pas
d'autre non je pense que maintenant on
est arrivé à un point d'équilibré je
pense surtout que ce qui toujours
demandé compromis devrait faire un pas
si au moins il pouvait dire on va
écouter même si on n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui satisfaits eh bien nous
n'allons pas
voter contre ce texte mais s'abstenir
ses dépositions qui existe dans la vie
démocratique
je peux comprendre plus l'abstention
finalement qu'avec je demande un geste
je te demande un geste de compréhension
et par un discours cynique ou à chaque
fois que quelqu'un fait un pas les
autres disent c'est pas mal mais on
voudrait plus bon et on voudrait tout
simplement
évidemment votre texte met totalement
dénaturé s'est passé c'est pas
raisonnable c'est pas comme ça ils
savent très bien quelque part alors que
qu'on ne peut pas avancer sur ce terrain
là c'est pas c'est pas crédible que ce
gouvernement qui est qui s'est orienté
sur l'article 2 c'est-à-dire la
négociation dans l'entreprise
c'est ce qui a permis de sauver excusez
moi mais des entreprises comme stx comme
psa c'est des milliers d'emplois
industriels qui ont été sauvés par des
négociations d'entreprise qui sont
d'ailleurs signé notamment par la cgt de
regarder et donc que vous excluez jean
marie le guen un geste notamment sur les
heures supplémentaires c'est ce que
demandent les frondeurs aujourd'hui
écouter les fondeurs demande toujours
l'abandon complet on pourrait négocier
sur les heures supplémentaires expliqué
un amendement qui puise n'y a pas de
sens que de vouloir limiter le champ de
la négociation sur des sujets qui sont
des sujets stratégiques qui permet de
réactiver donc vous restez fermes
le canal de communication est assez
étroit si l'issue est un poussin pas
faire nous allons était ouvert depuis
des semaines et maintenant ça suffit on
a fait à cette bien coûter on a fait
tout un tas de pas ils ont même été
contraints les uns des autres
oui alors maintenant s'il ya une posture
idéologique consiste à vouloir s'opposer
pour s'opposer
bon ben voila mais qu'on nous fasse pas
croire que casser ce que vous pensez il
ya une tendance à penser que à partir du
moment où ce que je regarde c'est contre
un texte initial qui était ce qu'il
était et la position des uns et des
autres qui a bougé qui a bougé le
gouvernement sur plein de points je vais
pas faire la liste ici des points après
ses amis du parti socialiste qui a
priori voterait leur sincérité en
faisant un pas est ce pas ça
consisterait à dire déjà je ne voterai
pas contre ce texte
n'oubliez pas que pas et ce qui se passe
écoutez nous verrons bien mais nous
avons bien l'intention de faire aboutir
cette loi était déjà plus ou moins vu
est ce que le gouvernement a dit qu'il
ne reculerait pas sur ce texte majeur
écoute étrange si ceux qui n'ont pas
bougé depuis le début à savoir un
certain nombre un petit groupe de
parlementaires qui préfèrent voter non
avec la droite plutôt que de voter un
texte qui est une réforme positive pour
les salariés j'attends de savoir si
vraiment ils s'ils se rendent bien
compte ici le prendront la
responsabilité de cette décision
dans la discussion nous allons voir il
ya encore il ya un temps du débat
parlementaire
c'est mardi le rendez-vous et mardi on
prévoit une très longue séance à
l'assemblée ce que des choses vont bien
jouer les cassandre mais nous verrons
bien
j'estime que jusqu'à présent c'est
largement le groupe socialiste la
commission les rapporteurs le
gouvernement qui ont fait des gestes qui
ont amélioré le texte qui devrait
permettre de branchement de d'avoir une
attitude différente de ce qui est bon
alors maintenant si c'est autre chose
que l'on cherche alors qu'il cherche
justement rien fait autre robe je pense
qu'on voit bien il ya une idée de
contestation radicale
politique - r oui ici ou là des arrière
pensées un peu ridicule et moi mais
voilà elles sont là parce que sur
justement cette question des primaires
les menaces qui ont été formulés
d'exclusion en cas de motion de censure
évidemment pour les députés socialistes
ou encore les investitures qui se sont
rendus aux tractations en ce moment dans
votre parti est ce qu'elles pèsent selon
vous sur super début de la saison jean
christophe cambadélis s'est exprimé
c'est le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste au delà des sens fouette
redescend pas voter une motion de
censure
oui mais au delà le même de la cua bien
sûr la cohérence intellectuelle mais
j'allais dire la décence morale on peut
pour blanc dre la décence morale bien
sûr comment voulez-vous que on puis on
puisse imaginer que dans une formation
politique et des gens qui demandent la
démission d'un gouvernement de cette
formation pour quoi faire
s'il y avait une démission il y aurait
des élections s'il y avait des élections
ça donnerait quoi une victoire une
victoire de deux ans donc si vous voulez
en gros on le voit bien d'ailleurs il ya
une certaine gauche alors c'est un état
d'esprit je dis pas qu'il est poussé
jusqu'au bout par tous mais c'est un
état d'esprit on a vu par exemple en
espagne
voyant une certaine gauche qui préfèrent
faire perdre la gauche et faire gagner
la droite plutôt que de composer moi je
suis là doivent partir ça de la
clarification vos oreilles doivent
partir c'est qu'il est il ya une
cohérence et une naissance qui fait que
les choses doivent se faire selon les
statuts mêmes de la formation politique
ce qui a été voté par le conseil
national du parti socialiste il ya une
quinzaine de jours et ce qu'a rappelé
jean-christophe cambadélis j'allais dire
dans le genre nous sommes capables de
tolérer des études qui sont un peu
bizarres lorsqu'on est une formation
politique c'est à dire quelque part oui
on est allé très loin quand même dans
l'idée que la collectivité qui est la
nôtre
faisait passer sur tout un tas
d'attitude qui étaient des attitudes
incompréhensibles lorsqu'on travaille
ensemble dans l'action politique c'est
la façon collective dans l'actualité
bien entendu il y avait aussi cette
question du bric site et s'est invitée
cette semaine à l'assemblée et au sénat
où il ya eu un débat je vous propose de
regarder ce résumé de cette séance avec
les a odinga après le breakbeat il y a
une chose sur laquelle les députés
s'accordent c'est la nécessité d'une
sortie rapide et d'une négociation ferme
avec le royaume-uni l'antre-2
l'ambiguïté ne sont plus possibles
on ne peut pas avoir quitté la maison
commune non plus payer les charges et
bénéficiez du toit des chambres et du
couvert accord trans partisan également
sur une critique virulente contre
l'union européenne l'europe ne doit plus
être perçu comme le cheval de troie pour
ne pas dire le dindon de la farce de la
mondialisation
à force de vouloir s'occuper de tout
l'union européenne passe à côté de
l'essentiel
trop de normes trop de règles trop de
procédures trop de détails et pas à
cette vision
l'europe ne marche plus et il faut
aujourd'hui tout changer mais sur les
responsabilités les solutions
l'opposition critiquent l'action ou
plutôt l'inaction du gouvernement
depuis quatre ans l'europe n'a plus de
visage
sinon celui de l'immobilisme car la
france est inexistante sans leadership
la droite propose tour à tour la
suppression de la commission européenne
la promesse de ne pas faire entrer la
turquie dans l'ue eu un référendum sur
un nouveau traité ou encore le
renforcement des frontières et c'est
seulement sur ce dernier point que le
gouvernement veut aujourd'hui insisté
dans le domaine de la sécurité dans le
domaine du renforcement des frontières
extérieures il a fallu que la france
agisse c'est elle qui a pris toutes les
initiatives les députés favorables à un
changement en europe
reste à savoir lequel la prochaine
élection présidentielle se fera entre
les européens et des autres
entre autres est une dimension
importante moi je pense que la france
aura à choisir entre
la construction d'un camp républicain ou
bien la venue au pouvoir dans des
conditions paris des conséquences
extrêmement dure comment on n'a pas
imaginé depuis peut-être 60 ans d'un
bloc réactionnaire
tout l'enjeu il est là et il va au delà
d'ailleurs de la gauche et de la droite
il va sur l'avenir effectivement de la
france de l'europe et oui quand non
seulement on connaît la position du
front national qui n'est pas de corriger
l'europe elle est de sortir de l'europe
bien et je le dis j'ai entendu un
certain nombre de choses joaillier par
exemple monsieur wauquiez se prononcer
pour la suppression de la commission
européenne dans un discours avec des
éléments et des propositions
démagogiques qui le met dans une
dynamique qui l'amènera à être aspiré
par la position du front national vous
savez il y aura il n'y aura pas 36
position il y aura ceux sur l'europe
mais pas simplement sur l'europe il y
aura ceux qui ont une attitude xénophobe
et ceux qui auront une attitude
républicaine
il y aura ceux qui ont une attitude de
construction de l'europe et de
renaissance européenne et ceux qui
seront pour la cm la droite elle se
laisse un peu aspiré par les positions
du fondation sûre je le dis je le
confirme il ya un débat y compris au
sein de la droite et dans la société
française entre des gens qui dans un
monde tout à fait bouleversé où on voit
d'ailleurs les pulsions populiste le
populisme en france à une cata une
caractéristique particulière il est
marqué par la xénophobie et par le
racisme
à la différence de populisme différents
qui peuvent exister encore dans d'autres
pays chez nous ce populisme est à
l'oeuvre il est à l'action et il aspire
une partie de la droite pas simplement
de l'extrader aussi ce populiste du fait
que les dirigeants en place le
n'explique et son n'exclut pas forcément
suffisamment les enjeux de l'europe et
notamment posé cette question quelle
légitimité
françois hollande est en gala merkel
couple franco-allemand ont-ils apporté
un nouveau projet pour l'europe sans la
grande bretagne alors qu'ils vont
affronter des élections dans leur pays
et qu'on dit le couple franco-allemand
un peu usé bon jeu
pas d'abord on est un an d'une élection
présidentielle on va pas se mettre tous
on va pas éteindre la lumière et
attendre pendant un an
voilà pourriez même plume invité bon
mais donc il l'histoire avance très vite
il ya des urgences on voit bien que la
question non vous avez raison de dire
qu'il ya d'un certain point de vue une
insuffisance de perspectives de sens
bien mais nous sommes dans un monde un
peu chaotique
quand je dis un peu c'est parce que je
ne veux pas devant vous dramatiser la
situation
mais bien sûr que nous sommes dans une
période qui est en train d'être
totalement bouleversé tous les repères
qui étaient les nôtres depuis
pratiquement la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale même s'il ya eu des nuances
dans les périodes que l'on a connues
depuis mais les repères principaux la
paix en europe la paix civile avec le
terrorisme le refus des idées xénophobes
et racistes
tout ça a été des acquis qui ont
fonctionné dans ce pays pendant 60 70
ans et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que ses
repères ses points de fix de pensées
politiques ne sont plus aussi clair
qu'avant alors je vous propose de
revenir à l'assemblée dans le débat
national où un texte plus consensuel
était à l'ordre du jour le projet dit
plec comme projet de loi égalité
citoyenneté une loi en trois actes comme
nous l'expliquent astrid de vilaines le
titre un est porté par patrick kanner le
ministre de la ville et de la jeunesse
il est temps le service civique pour
toucher plus de jeunes et permet à toute
personne de prendre des congés pour
s'engager dans la réserve civique des
mesures pour faciliter l'accès au permis
de conduire ont été ajoutés les jeunes
pourront demander leur émancipation
à partir de 16 ans des amendements du
gouvernement pour mieux contrôler
l'école à domicile et les établissements
hors contrat avec l'état ont également
été adoptée non sans polémique c'est
aussi de pouvoir rentrer dans de bonnes
conditions au domicile
dans le dossier des familles pour
vérifier et vous l'avez évoqué om qu
elle l environnement le conseil
constitutionnel aura à se prononcer
parce que nous le saisir on nous le
saisiront sur ce point autre grand volet
du texte le logement avec la ministre
emmanuelle cosse chaque commune devra
accueillir 25 % des foyers les plus
modestes dans ces logements sociaux le
préfet a plus de poids pour faire
appliquer la loi sru les communes qui ne
respectent pas la loi sur le logement
social se verront privés de dotation
contre l'avis du gouvernement françois
pupponi a fait adopté de nombreux
amendements pour lutter contre la
ghettoïsation des quartiers
si on ne met pas des planches et dans
les quartiers les plus ghettoïser alors
ne nous racontons pas d'histoires nous
ne voulons pas lutter contre le ghetto
stores est ce que vous proposez c'est
une discrimination indirecte qui est
anticonstitutionnelle enfin le dernier
chapitre de cette loi concerne l'égalité
réelle
la secrétaire d'état ericka bareigt
défend ce troisième chapitre il renforce
l'apprentissage du français lutte contre
les discriminations et aggrave les
peines pour racisme antisémitisme
sexisme un amendement des radicaux de
gauche a été adopté pour garantir à tous
les enfants l'accès à la cantine et sans
discrimination
alors juste une question d'être sur cet
amendement adopté par françois pupponi
de françois pupponi adopté contre l'avis
du gouvernement
c'est pas un progrès pour vous il dit
vouloir lutter contre la ghettoïsation
il ya deux logiques qui se sont
présentés qui sont toutes les deux à ses
légitimes
évidemment favoriser l'accès au logement
des plus démunis
mais de l'autre côté ne pas renforcer le
caractère des ghettos j'ai d'ailleurs
cette loi elle est d'abord né de la
lutte contre les ghettos donc je pense
que il ya eu depuis votre reportage
discussions entre mac os et bien c'est
françois publiés et ils ont trouvé un
accord
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut prendre
en compte les priorités sociales d'un
côté et les priorités de l'organisation
sociale de l'autre c'est un texte plus
consensuel que la loi elle conneries ce
projet de loin ou vous savez
c'est un texte qui beaucoup de choses
dans ce texte beaucoup beaucoup on dit
on parle de loi fourre-tout même parce
que le périmètre est très large
parce que je pense que c'est une loi qui
touche effectivement à la vie
quotidienne dans les quartiers et qui à
part notamment et qui donc à partir de
la touche à des choses qui sont
différentes mais qui sont aussi
importantes pour les jeunes pour la vie
de ces quartiers pour l'avenir lutter
contre les ghettos c'est un axe
stratégique vous savez et cette loi
permet déjà des avancées considérables
faudra peut-être réfléchir à d'autres
dispositions encore mais en tout état de
cause c'est un travail de longue haleine
auquel le gouvernement s'attaque avec
courage parce que l'inaction de ce point
de vue serait sans doute plus simple
alors on va s'intéresser à présent aux
comptes publics c'est une tradition
chaque année la cour des comptes remet
son rapport annuel
et elle tire évidemment c'est une
sonnette d'alarmé sur la réduction des
déficits
regardez ce résumé signés jordan uc la
douche froide pour les finances
publiques
2 7% du pib en 2010 est c'est l'objectif
de déficit fixé par la france mais
inatteignable selon le dernier rapport
de la cour des comptes
les sages du palais cambon s'inquiètent
des risques de dérapage des dépenses de
l'état compris entre 3,2 et 6,4
milliards d'euros
il pointe du doigt des finances
publiques affectées de fragilité majeur
en cause les aides aux agriculteurs la
hausse de la rémunération des
fonctionnaires
l'augmentation programmée des dépenses
militaires ou l'atténuation des efforts
demandés aux communes
nous avons un niveau de dépense élevé si
on le compare 1 par rapport à d'autres
pays qui ne sont comparables et on a des
résultats qui ne correspondent pas à ses
niveaux de dépenses publiques
nous avons un décalage très fort entre
le niveau des dépenses publiques et les
résultats de l'action publique quand on
la mesure quand on les va nu après avoir
ramené le déficit à 3 5% en 2015 le
gouvernement table sur 3,3 à la fin de
l'année objectif atteignable et modeste
selon la cour des comptes
mais c'est en 2017 que les sages prévoit
un dépassement de 0,3 point de pib par
rapport à l'objectif de 2 7% depuis
bruxelles françois hollande a réagi il
estime que l'objectif fixé par le
gouvernement est largement tenable alors
vous avez entendu didier
migaud vous ne respecterait pas vos
engagements dit il la cour des comptes
était un peu dans son rôle et puis
peut-être d'ailleurs dans un rôle
qu'elle joue un peu qu elle surjoue un
peu depuis quelques années dans sage au
dessus de la mêlée oui normal c'est à
dire qu'elle se coule la sonnette
c'est tout à fait légitime mais il faut
pas interpréter cela comme étant la
vérité définitive puisque elle l'a déjà
fait d'autres années précédentes et à
chaque fois elle s'est trouvée démenti
par les faits non pas qu'elle disait des
choses qui était inexacte mais elle
prend une photo alors que le film n'est
pas terminée donc on est dans une
période où il ya eu effectivement qui le
contestent moi j'aimerais avoir au delà
des petites phrases véritablement un
gouvernement de droite des gens de
droite qui dirait à 20 nous assurent les
agriculteurs elles ont pas le droit aux
aides
je vous promets sur les fonctionnaires
on n'ira pas sur l'augmentation etc etc
qui disent il ya eu des cadeaux ces
derniers temps c'est ce qui est nouveau
c'est panique à dos les cadeaux les
fonctionnaires en l'occurrence il avait
pas eu d'augmentation depuis cinq ans au
lycée edgar duhr jours voilà l
agriculture se dire c'est les premiers
et les parlementaires de droite qui je
suis bien passé pour le voir nous
assaillent pour nous dire il faut faire
ci sur le lait sur la viande sur les
poulets sur le port et ses bons sur les
allocations familiales ont fait jamais
assez pour les couches supérieures
etc etc il n'y a pas un endroit il n'y a
pas un endroit un domaine de l'action
publique où la droite n'intervient pas
toutes les semaines aux questions au
sénat à l'assemblée en demandant plus de
dépenses
et puis il a tout d'un coup on résout un
certain nombre de problèmes de façon
raisonnable
on nous dit assez des cadeaux enfin
c'est pas raisonnable en tout cas
sérieux un problème de fond il ya cette
dette publique française qui flambe de
1137 milliards d'euros et alors on se
parle je prends pas les stabiliser mais
en tout cas elle semble pas plaint pas
mais
vrai est importante mais elle est
importante
et alors il faut bien aussi trouver les
moyens de la réduit vous avez ça c'est
fait pour ne pas sentir les coups du
fameux pacte des facilités sont ramener
la dette publique est stabilisée et il
mettra un certain temps évidemment à
éponger ce qui a été acquis depuis deux
entre 2008 et 2012 600 milliards d'euros
il ya aujourd'hui environ le tiers dont
justement ci s'est stabilisé il ne faut
pas que ça mais repartent avait bien
raison c'est ce que nous faisons c'est
ce que nous faisons
à la différence de nos prédécesseurs je
rappelle qu'ils ont fait une
augmentation de la dette de 600
milliards c'est-à-dire de 33% de la 33 %
des 2000 milliards pour faire vite
c'était monsieur sarkozy entre 2008 et
en quatre ans bon nous depuis nous avons
stabilisé limité dans un premier temps
stabiliser dans un deuxième les déficits
se réduisent
voilà c'est le travail que nous faisons
alors maintenant est ce qui est ce qu'il
ya une solution pour y aller à la hache
ah bah oui on peut ne plus rembourser
les frais d'assurance maladie si on pose
que c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
bon mai 2010 et qu'on perd bien que ce
n'est pas sérieux de profondeur un
travail sérieux de vigilance que fait
christian eckert des travail de réforme
ce que nous avons fait sur les
collectivités territoriales sur la
simplification des procédures de l'état
ça donne des résultats mais ça met un
certain temps bien sûr mais ces
résultats ils sont là à là sur la table
des élections comme meilleur notre enjeu
de mission à faire des annonces et puis
après du pipeau la droite elle dit il
faut diminuer le et pense 500 milliards
quand il était au gouvernement et tous
les jours tous les jours à l'assemblée
vous êtes bien passé pour le voir et au
sénat et viennent nous dire on veut plus
de dépenses allez comprendre quelque
chose
et pour vous c'est aussi ce que vous
dites sur les programmes de la droite
donc si j'ai bien compris la droite
c'est un jour le lundi on dit qu'on va
diminuer les déficits et les dépenses
publiques et le mardi le mercredi et le
jeudi on intervient à l'assemblée et au
sénat pour demander plus de dépenses ça
autre enjeu à l'arrêt pour 2017 ce
seront les institutions nicolas sarkozy
a livré quelques pistes cette semaine
stéphane amalia
nicolas sarkozy pose les derniers jalons
du programme des républicains pour 2017
avec un nouvel objectif
refonder les institutions de la vème
république première mesure la
suppression d'un tiers des
parlementaires
ça donnerait 400 députés 200 deux
sénateurs au lieu des 577 députés
actuels et des 348 sénateurs actuels
étant entendu que le redécoupage serait
pour 2022
autre mesure plus urgentes pour nicolas
sarkozy le retour au cumul des mandats
il nécessitait pour ses soutiens et un
moyen de faire des économies
le mandat unique et ça coûte plus cher
parce que là où vous avez un seul homme
politique qui est député maire ou
sénateur maire mais ça coûte moins cher
que d'avoir un sénateur qui ne fait que
ça ait un maire qui fait que ça autre
projet le recours plus systématique au
référendum
nous sommes les héritiers de la famille
gaulliste le général de gaulle avait
placé les fans roma et la participation
en réalité du peuple à des décisions
stratégiques au coeur de la
reconstitution la vème république
le programme devra être validé ce samedi
lors du conseil national du parti
il sera déserté par bruno le maire est
sans doute alain juppé a lors du
référendum de changement d'institutions
et il revient également sur le non cumul
des mandats sont pensez quoi
je pense je serai une très mauvaise
chose mais ça ne se fera pas ça fait
partie des promesses ce qu'il n'y aura
jamais d'accord dans le pays pour
revenir contre cette loi et donc je veux
dire la majorité qui éventuellement
voudrait faire passer cette loi se
trouverait devant une critique de
l'opinion publique
c'est la vieille politique c'est
vraiment ce qu'il ya de plus ringard ou
40 ans bruno le maire bah écoute et sur
ce point là c'est plutôt lui qui parle
comme quelqu'un de gauche
charge aux écoles parce que cette loi
c'est nous qui l'avons fait voter et
donc il n'y aura pas de retour au
mandarinat avec des gens qui sont ni à
l'assemblée nationale ni au sein
d'ailleurs quand nicolas sarkozy dit il
faudrait passer à 400 députés
jallet dix ans c'est une réforme à
laquelle on peut peut-être réfléchir
mais ça n'a de sens que si ses députés
sont justement beaucoup plus présents à
l'assemblée nationale comment voudriez
vous qu'ils soient en même temps
président de région
merde vous imaginez aujourd'hui que les
français veulent que les responsables
des intercommunalités qu'il représente
sans parler des métropoles ou des
régions des dépenses et du vol des gens
qu'ils soient là qui travaillent pas des
gens qui soient totalement absent alors
on fait 400 députés donc on va
travailler plus à l'assemblée de sable
un d'ailleurs c'est ça plutôt d'accord
mais alors ça ça nous éloigne encore
plus de l'idée du cul mais ça n'est pas
sérieux
certains en europe pourtant réduit le
nombre de sièges de parlementaires
ça ne va pas ça n'irait pas dans le sens
de l'histoire si je vous ai dit que je
trouve que c'est une réflexion qui n'est
ce pas qui n'a dont il n'a d'ailleurs
absolument pas le monopole
et c'est encore accepté c'est un peu
court on voit bien que derrière tout ça
il ya un affichage un petit peu démago
pour ne pas dire quand je dis un petit
peu c'est que je ne veux pas être trop
critique ou plus directement détonnant
fatick voilà mais il n'y a rien derrière
elle à le penser on assure les
institutions parce qu est-ce qu il ya un
problème de fonctionnement de nos
institutions est directement de la
démocratie oui il y à une aspiration
démocratique et il ya un état une
certaine façon de faire fonctionner je
dis bien une certaine façon de faire
fonctionner la vème république qui n'est
pas totalement satisfaisante et donc je
pense que de façon très sereine
il faut aller vers autre chose vers une
évolution qui n'est d'ailleurs ne
justifie pas nécessairement atteindre
une évolution des institutions
mais une autre pratique vraiment pas
dans un instant mais d'abord la suite de
cette émission après la loi travail il
ya encore du travail pour députés et
sénateurs le parlement siège depuis ce
vendredi 1er juillet en session
extraordinaire une quinzaine de projets
loi est à l'ordre du jour dans les deux
chambres
le programme en accéléré avec kylie ann
bridoux l'acf est ouverte
premier grand texte la loi travail de
retour à l'assemblée le projet toujours
contesté le gouvernement pourrait à
nouveau avoir recours aux 49 3 pour
adopter le texte sans le vote plus
consensuel le projet de loi égalité et
citoyenneté pour un vote est une
explication de vote dans l'hémicycle ce
projet modifie notamment l'attribution
des logements sociaux
le 7 juillet place au débat
d'orientation budgétaire
également au menu de cette session
extraordinaire de textes sur la justice
le projet de loi organique sur le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
puis en nouvelle lecture le projet de
modernisation de la justice du 21e
siècle
les députés enfin examineront en
nouvelle lecture le projet de loi
liberté indépendance et pluralisme des
médias
côté sénat la loi sapin de ouvre la
session extraordinaire en nouvelle
lecture le 6 juillet c'est le projet de
loi organique relatif aux magistrats et
au conseil supérieur de la magistrature
qui passe à nouveau devant les sénateurs
avant une nouvelle lecture le 11 du
projet de loi biodiversité dernier texte
pour les sénateurs la discussion
générale du projet de loi modifiant
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
la date officielle de clôture n'est pas
encore connue mais le parlement devrait
suspendre ses travaux le 22 juillet sauf
surprise de dernière minute jean marie
le guen ce que vous en savez un peu plus
sur le calendrier de fin de session
parle du 22 juillet vous avez une date
plus précise
jonah bhl interrompre les travaux
parlementaires cette date là et
concernant la loi travail ce que vous
pensez que le 6 juillet au matin elle
sera toujours à l'ordre du jour de la
séance publique
sans vouloir jouer les cassandre mais
maintenant je m'écoutais je vais rompre
instant oui elle sera en débat et la loi
sera adopté avant la
avant l'été est-ce que vous avez déjà
prévue pour l'année prochaine
d'autres textes d'autres textes qui ne
sont pas on a vu qu'ils n'étaient pas en
quoi il ya plusieurs textes qui doivent
venir des textes égalité touchant aux
territoires d'outre-mer et un texte sur
la montagne c'était un gros effort il
est dans une année de campagne
non ce ne sera pas si vous voulez parler
de grands textes économiques et sociaux
pour l'instant non encore qu'on a quand
même un budget vous avez parfaitement
raison il y aura le budget le budget de
l'assurance maladie la sécurité sociale
pardon donc il y aura
des éléments importants du débat
politique puis la fin de l'année est
toujours réservé à la session budgétaire
pour l'essentiel alors on va passer à la
loupe du scan tu me verras c'est
viennent nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
fait tout de suite qu'elle ou bonjour
jean marie le guen jours on va parler un
peu si vous voulez bien de la primaire à
gauche puisqu'elle va avoir lieu
on va regarder ce que vous en disiez il
ya quelques il ya quelques semaines vous
disiez ceux qui sont prononcés le plus
fortement pour une primaire à gauche
sont ceux qui veulent écarter la
candidature de françois hollande ont
pourtant aujourd'hui françois hollande
il s'est rallié à l'idée d'une d'une
primaire est ce que vous regrettez
justement que ce scrutin ait lieu que
j'ai un avis partagé mais il faudrait
peut-être un peu plus dedans je sais pas
si on en a mais c'est un petit peu bon
écoutez je pense que c'est une idée qui
est très reçus par nos compatriotes que
nous avons mis en oeuvre et qui a le
mérite de dépasser des appareils pour
dire les choses
à gauche et à droite qui sont assez
sclérose et donc de ce point de vue
c'est un élément positif et démocratique
là où j'ai un peu plus de doute c'est
que cette primaire organise à gauche à
droite un débat où les gens de gauche
par là aux gens de gauche et les jambes
droites aux gens de droite or je crois
que la démocratie c'est pas d'essayer de
se comparer à l'intérieur d'une part de
marché si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
qui est assez limité mais c'est
d'essayer d'attirer des gens qui ne se
sentent ni de gauche ni de droite voire
même de débattre aussi avec des gens de
droite et donc l'inde
l'inconvénient des primaires c'est de
rester chacun sur une zone une fan zone
en quelque sorte puisque c'est l'époque
et donc on parle à sa fan zone n'en
parle pas à l'ensemble des français je
suis c'est ce qui me gêne un peu dans
cette affaire fait selon vous que
françois hollande justement accepté
finalement de ce cet exercice rond parce
qu'il ya eu une polémique qui a été
menée sur le sujet bon là il faut et
deuxièmement c'est pas vraiment non cc
c'est bon moi j'étais assez réticent
s'agissant du président de la république
je trouve ça enfin nous encore une fois
c'est je veux dire nous sommes au
contraire dans une attitude d'ouverture
alors jeu il fallait pas de confusion
croire que la gauche est un camp unanime
dans lequel on il s'agirait de
distinguer entre les uns et les autres
juste sur leur physique ou leur talent
oratoire n'est pas sérieux il faut pour
qu'une primaires aient du sens il faut
qu'elle ait lieu sur la base d'un
territoire politique bon nous sommes la
gauche réformiste
nous sommes la gauche républicaine nous
ne sommes pas à la gauche radicaliser
nous sommes pas l'extrême gauche
pourtant donc mélanger notre primaire à
l'extrême gauche
ça ne s'est pas fait évidemment
mélenchon n'a jamais voulu le parti
communiste non plus
non c'est pas l'extrême gauche non non
pas du tout c'est une gauche
contestataire et puis qui hésite un
petit peu les différents sentiers qu'il
pourrait sur lesquelles il pourrait
s'aventurer
c'est toujours pas très claires de ce
point du manuel valls alors pas le parle
de deux gauches irréconciliables est-ce
que vous souscrivez à cette analyse est
ce que justement arnaud montebourg il
fait partie de l'autre gauche jeu quand
il parle de gauches irréconciliables il
considère que dans la gauche radicaliser
il y a aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
parfois violent mais même qui ont tout
simplement un assentiment à la violence
qui n'est pas acceptable ou qui ont un
assentiment au communautarisme qui n'est
pas acceptable ou qui ont un assentiment
à une exacerbation des aides sociales
qui est dangereuse voilà et ce clivage
là il passe pas à mon avis entre la
gauche et la gauche contestataire il
passe à l'intérieur de la gauche
contestataire
il y à une gauche républicaine qui est
la gauche réformiste est sans doute une
gauche plus plus rugueuse plus robuste
mais qui est aussi une gauche
républicaine chez les communistes il ya
une tradition de la gauche républicaine
et puis il ya une tradition de de vue
j'allais dire de d'acceptation de
tolérance à la violence ou à la haine
sociale qui me posent formulation du
cobra même communauté
aussi la question justement
communautarisme de votre récent ouvrage
la gauche qui vient vous parlez des
islamo gauchiste en désignant certaines
figures de la gauche radicale ou
clémentine autain c'est une question
centrale selon vous la question de
l'identité
vous dites que justement il faut avoir
le courage de dire les choses pour
combattre le front national mais
l'islamo gauchisme c'est aussi un terme
qui est employé au front national est ce
que ces représentations de france de
laïcité même et de république sans un
point d'étape qui fait polémique et non
ses jeux les employés parce que j'estime
qu'il correspond au fait qu'il y à une
fraction de la gauche radicaliser qui
pour des raisons semble-t-il mal placé
considère par définition que l'on doit
être tolérant et compréhensif avec un
certain nombre de gens qui se pare des
vertus de la victimisation
je pense que c'est une erreur il faut
évidemment être compréhensif et quand je
parle islamo-gauchiste je parle pas de
l'islam je ne peux pas je parle de cette
fraction radicaliser fondamentaliste de
l'islam avec lesquels quand on est
républicain laïque de gauche avec un
certain nombre de valeurs de gauche
on ne peut pas avoir d'accord voilà non
sur françois hollande
il ya en tout cas est la question la
primeur au dessus de la femme par
exemple sujet mois ci la gauche met de
côté le statut de la femme d'un côté
l'égalité homme femme le fait qu' il y
ait des pressions qui s'exercent sur les
comportements des individus à
l'intérieur d'un certain nombre de
milieux d'un certain nombre de quartiers
c'est totalement contraire mais je suis
révulsé du point de vue de mes valeurs
de gauche
ça concerne le parti socialiste ça il
peut y avoir il compris au sein du parti
socialiste des gens qui ne mesurent pas
aujourd'hui les dégâts et qui par
opportunisme peuvent ça existe dans tous
les partis d'ailleurs victimes si je vis
personne je dis simplement vidic
hivernale il peut y avoir et on sait
bien qu'il ya eu ici dans toutes les
formations politiques compris
républicaine des tentations de suivre la
problématique communautariste pour des
raisons électorales ça existe voilà donc
j'appelle les consciences parce que je
c'est que les gens qui parfois pratique
le communautarisme ouvrons une tolérance
vis-à-vis du communautarisme
ils le font par électoraliste pas et non
pas par conviction et donc je les
appelle à suivre leurs convictions
est-ce que je suis pas si ça va être la
mission de est-ce que ça va être la
mission de manuel valls
après 2010 est de justement faire
évoluer évoluer le logiciel du ps sur
ces questions logiciel du ps il évolue
d'ores et déjà la clarification elle se
fait alors moi je suis celui qui
l'assument peut-être plus clairement que
d'autres mais enfin on voit bien que la
gauche est en train de bouger elle a
bougé il ya maintenant une dizaine
d'années sur les questions de sécurité
elle a bougé il ya déjà un certain
nombre d'années sur la question de la
laïcité et je suis plus précis
s'agissant du communautarisme et elle a
bougé sur les questions économiques et
sociales
elle a bougé évidemment la petite
question sur la nation sur la république
elle bouge cette gauche elle devient
social réformiste allons un peu de
françois hollande et que son interview
dans les échos il a multiplié les
annonces sur les baisses d'impôt ou la
prime à l'embauché cice c'est quoi c'est
l'ébauché d'un programme présidentiel la
droite elle dénonce déjà des mesures
électoralistes
oui mais encore une fois il est il quand
ils les promettre multiplié par cinq
ce sont des mesures de bon sens et quand
une façon très pragmatique le président
de la république annonce des choses
concrètes qui vont se mettre en place
dès les mois qui viennent lassé des
cadeaux alors à l'écran jacques rossi
sur un radeau mina qui se projette sur
l'après 2010 est aussi clairement oui
mais sur donc ça veut ça veut dire
quelque chose ça veut dire que il est au
nul dans la chair soit la langue de bois
évidemment b d'ailleurs
sommes là bien sûr qu'ils se placent
dans ces fait campagne pour ça il fait
pas campagne
il gère et il dit je m'engage une
politique qui a vocation à aller au delà
de 2010 merci merci jean marie le guen
cerveau de la fin on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine bonne semaine